did you enjoy Doctor Strange in the
Multiverse of Madness this is a question
I genuinely want to know the answer to
please put your answers in the comments
down below the reason I asked this is
because it looks like Sam Ry could be
returning to direct Doctor Strange 3
plus and maybe or other Marvel Studios
films either way it sounds like Marvel
Studios really wants Sam Remy to return
to direct a film for the MCU and the
reason I ask if you like Doctor Strange
in the Multiverse of mad or not is
because the movie tends to get a lot of
hate online but that could be a small
majority of the loudest people because
Multiverse of Madness in 2022 won best
movie at the People's Choice Awards so
clearly it was liked Enough by enough
people to have won the People's Choice
Awards and if that is the case if the
majority of people like that movie then
they're going to like the fact that
Marvel wants to bring back Sam Ry and if
you don't like that fact maybe I could
change your mind by the end of this
video because Sam Ramy as most people
know is a Marvel Legend he directed the
first three Spider-Man films with Toby
Maguire he did get a lot of hate for
Spider-Man 3 and he was reluctant to
return to superhero films for an
extremely long time after that he
admitted and it was a really big deal
for him to return for Doctor Strange in
the Multiverse of Madness to direct and
contribute to writing the script and
mind you the script had already been
written by Scott derkson he wrote the
whole movie and then he had a
disagreement with Kevin fige and Marvel
about how the movie should be more rated
off more horror more gory and basically
Marvel said no we can't push it that far
and that wasn't the movie Scott derkson
wanted so he departed ways at least as
far as we know that's what happened so
Sam Ramy came into a film that had
already been written completely and
basically had to do the film over kind
of according to Marvel's wants and needs
with a script already written a new
writer on it as well with Michael
Waldren working with him it just wasn't
the best scenario so if you didn't like
Multiverse of Madness it wasn't really
Sam ry's fault and for what he was
supposed to accomplish with the movie I
feel like he did he did make sort of a
horror movie as much as you can make for
a Marvel PG13 Disney movie in the MCU
and if you return to the MCU to direct
and write something from scratch I think
it would turn out phenomenal if it's
anything like Spider-Man 1 and two and
the good parts that we got from
Multiverse of Madness because there were
some amazing scenes in it we could
probably expect an amazing film plus we
know Toby Maguire Spider-Man is going to
return again at some point in time and
it would be really cool to see Sam Ry
and Toby Maguire working together again
because according to Insider Daniel rpk
Sam Ry is wanted by Marvel Studios to
direct not only the next Doctor Strange
movie Doctor Strange 3 but also possibly
Avengers Secret Wars and this would most
likely be a either or scenario he most
likely wouldn't direct Doctor Strange 3
and Secret Wars however According to
some other recent reports that we've
heard Marvel Studios will most likely
want somebody to direct both Avengers
King Dynasty and Avengers Secret Wars
which does make sense for Infinity war
and endgame they had the Russa Brothers
direct both for continuity purposes and
story purposes and since King Dynasty
and Secret Wars are essentially a part
one and a part two you would assume they
would basically want the same thing the
same goes for the writers which have
already been announced it is actually
Michael Waldren the writer of Loki
season 1 the main writer for Doctor
Strange in the Multiverse of Madness
however like I mentioned he came in
after the fact after Scott derkson
already wrote his script so Marvel
Studios obviously likes Michael Waldren
enough and likes the work that he's done
to hire him as the director for both new
Avengers films the direct report from
Daniel rpk states that doctor strange 3
is in development at Marvel Studios the
studio wants Sam Ry to return to direct
the film but he is in consideration to
direct Avengers Secret Wars so Doctor
Strange 3 is in development reportedly
at Marvel Studios right now which we
knew Doctor Strange in the Multiverse of
madness's post credit scene obviously
set up Doctor Strange 3 in a really big
way with cleus showing up in the post
credit to recruit Doctor Strange to help
fix an incursion that doctor strange
caused now we do know a little bit about
what Doctor Strange 3 is going to be
about according to insiders according to
Alex P at the cosmic circus Doctor
Strange 3 is going to adapt a Time Runs
Out story in the comics time Runs Out is
an event that took place right before
the events of Avengers Secret Wars
basically what's going to happen is time
will run out meaning The Avengers will
run out of time the Multiverse will
essentially start to be destroyed and
collapse basically they're going to be
on the brink of a multiversal disaster
and time essentially runs out and the
disaster happens from what we know
Doctor Strange is going to be a core
problem for the Multiverse this was also
set up in Doctor Strange 2 where they
said the biggest threat to the universe
and in this case the Multiverse is Dr
Steven strange reportedly Doctor Strange
3 will introduce the group The Black
priests which Clea is a part of they are
a multiversal group that is going around
trying to prevent the destruction of of
the Multiverse and in many different
universes they have found that doctor
strange is the cause for many incursions
throughout the Multiverse and this is
reflected in the post credit scene in
Doctor Strange 2 where cleus says very
clearly Doctor Strange caused an
incursion and she is trying to fix it as
a part of this multiversal Protection
Team we can call them now in the comics
dror strange is actually a part of the
group and the leader of the group so
they could be leaning that way towards
Avengers King Dynasty and Secret Wars to
where ultimately Doctor Strange is going
to be a key player in in defending and
protecting and restoring the Multiverse
once essentially time runs out and it
collapses because we know that's
essentially what secret Wars is going to
be about we know the Avengers will most
likely lose in King Dynasty then they
will essentially have to avenge the
universe and Avengers Secret Wars and
restore it and this is also where we are
supposedly going to get our soft reboot
which makes sense if the Multiverse kind
of gets destroyed and then rebooted it
makes sense that the entire MCU would be
soft rebooted as well so Dr strange 3 is
going to be an incredibly important film
for Avengers Secret Wars and the
Multiverse Saga in general and
apparently according to Daniel rpk
Marvel Studios want Sam Remy to direct
this film but they also might want him
for Secret Wars and this makes sense
because Secret Wars is going to have
just a ton of different characters from
a bunch of different universes we
already know that basically Hugh
Jackman's Wolverine Toby McGuire
Spider-Man Deadpool Doctor Strange our
Spider-Man Tom Holland Spider-Man and
some other key Xmen characters from the
old Fox Universe are going to be pretty
much the main team of Secret Wars along
with a bunch of other cameos that we
know are going to happen we've also
heard recently that variant of Robert
Downey Jr's Iron Man Scarlett
Johansson's Black Widow and Chris Evans
Captain America are going to be
returning in the film as well which we
all expected the actors can play dumb
all they want that is their job they
cannot say that they are going to return
but basically we all expect them to be
in the film so Sam Ry who has directed a
past Marvel project when Marvel really
first got going for Cinema with the
first Spider-Man trilogy and who also
directed a newer MCU film that is a part
of the Multiverse Saga Doctor Strange 2
is pretty fitted for the job since he's
been a part of the past and now the
present and now it looks like he could
be a pretty big part of the future of
Marvel Studios if he goes on to direct
Doctor Strange 3 or Avengers Secret Wars
and again like I mentioned Marvel
Studios probably wants one director for
both Kang Dynasty and secret War so he
could be the director for Kang Dynasty
as as well which would mean we would get
the doctor strange 2 Team Michael
Waldren and Sam Ry back for Avengers
King Dynasty and Avengers Secret Wars
what do you think about this would you
rather Sam Ramy come back to direct
Doctor Strange 3 or would you like him
to direct both of the new Avengers films
let us know your thoughts in the
comments down below and again let us
know did you like Doctor Strange 2 or
not and are you excited or concerned if
Sam Ramy comes back to direct either of
these movies don't forget to like the
video and leave a comment down below and
if you leave a comment and subs
subscribe to the channel you are
automatically entered in our giveaway
for a chance to win a PS5 an Xbox series
X some Marvel Legends items or some DC
items the winner gets to pick one item
and we pick one winner at the end of
each month as always thank you all so
much for watching wolof woof